brought to you by the PlayStation
experience in Las Vegas take part in all
the announcements panels and early game
previews December 6th and 7th hey guys
it is Monday the 24th of November today
my name is Jess McDonald and you're
watching Gamespot
news it's been a while since we last
checked in with Star Citizen or as I
like to call it the giant pile of money
which keeps inexplicably growing said
pile is almost at $63 million
the campaign for Wing Commander Creator
Chris Roberts's upcoming PC space Sim
has had a whopping 6 59,000 backers who
have ponied up just under 62.9 million
bucks recently a fleet of in-game ships
and gear has gone on sale at the gamees
website which may have helped boost that
figure recently Roberts hopes to put 100
million into the game just from
crowdfunding in addition to the funds
coming from developer Cloud Imperium Gam
and things are so not going well for 343
Industries or Microsoft or anybody
trying to play halo the Master Chief
collection and it seems things are going
to get worse before they get better the
dev have acknowledged that the
matchmaking issues still affect far too
many players they also noted that while
some are seeing improvements after the
numerous patches last week's content
update accident brought with it new user
interface bugs 343 are promising that
the large team sizes and uneven matchups
in multiplayer will be reset to the
default once the matchmaking issues are
resolved it's just hard to say when that
will be if you want to check out some of
the official steps for troubleshooting
the game in the meantime you can check
out the details of those on Gamespot
finally Batman is back in our lives it
may have suffered a massive delay but we
just got our first in a new series of
gameplay clips from Arkham Knight the
video called ace chemicals infiltration
which you watching right about now
features an infiltration of what I can
assume is a place called ace chemicals
Batman does the Epic feere Tak down
thing electrocutes Bad Dudes and
Batmobiles his way through concrete
walls it's all fairly sweet as for your
question of the day let me know what you
think of Batman Arkham Knight so far and
if you'll be picking up the game you can
head to gam swop for more stories on
things like Microsoft congratulating
Sony and neither of them getting hacked
that is it for me today more new will be
headed your way same time tomorrow but
be sure to have yourselves a good one
until
then